so first i want to recap the metal
learning problem and black box metal
learning just to provide
a little bit of review and refresher
then today we'll talk primarily about
optimization based metal learner meta
learning and
we'll cover the
overall approach we'll compare
optimization based and black box meta
learning
uh conceptually we'll talk about some of
the challenges with optimization based
meta learning and some solutions i also
noticed that there's a typo here that
i'll
fix with the
with the pen so it should be
optimization-based my learning
and then we'll also talk about a case
study that applies metal learning to the
problem of land cover classification
and the goals for the end of the lecture
are
hopefully you'll be able to understand
the basics of optimization based metal
learning as well as generally how to go
about implementing them
and also understand the trade-offs
between black box and optimization based
learning approaches
great
um so
let's get started
to recap what we talked a bit about last
time
um we talked about transfer learning and
also the meta learning problem
and we talked about how these different
problem settings relate also with
multi-task learning so in multi-test
learning the goal is to solve multiple
tasks all at once
in metal learning the goal is to given
data from multiple tasks be able to
leverage that to quickly solve and do
tasks with a small amount of data
and in transfer learning
the goal is to solve a new task after
solving some previous source tasks by
transferring knowledge
um although kind of the lines between
transfer learning and middle learning
may be blurred a little bit uh and could
be
memory can be viewed as an instantiation
of transfer learning
if you sort of view the source task as
the set of n meta trading tasks
in both transfer learning and metal
learning is generally impractical to
access the previous tasks
and in all of these settings the tasks
must share some amount of structure in
order to actually see a benefit from
these methods in comparison to
independently training on each of the
tasks
we also talked about kind of what an
example metal learning problem might
look like so
for example if you look at
fuchsia image classification from the
mini image data set mini imagenet data
set
at test time your goal is to classify
new examples after seeing a tiny
training data set of only five examples
and the way that you go about trying to
solve this few shot learning problem is
to structure image data from other image
classes into different mini train sets
and test sets and
learn how to learn each of each of these
tasks so that you're well prepared to
solve the meta test task at the top with
held out image classes
and of course this is an example in the
image classification domain but you can
replace each of these tasks
with regression problems language
generation problems skill learning
problems really a wide range of machine
learning problems
and then
after we talked about the metal learning
problem statement we also talked about
black box adaptation
and this is a class of metal learning
algorithms that basically take your
training data set for each of these
tasks pass this through a neural network
that produces the weights of another
neural network phi i
and then you take new examples that you
want to be able to classify and pass
that through your network with vi to get
the corresponding prediction
and this whole process is kind of
trained end to end with respect to your
performance on
these held out these test examples for
each of your tasks
um and this could
be viewed as a general form of
neural network that takes this input a
training data set and a new input and is
trained to be able to make a correct
prediction for that new input
okay and then one of the main benefits
of this approach is it's very expressive
and one of the main downsides is that
it's a pretty challenging optimization
problem because you need to actually
learn to process data and learn from
data completely from scratch from a
randomly initialized neural network of
theta
okay so that's a brief recap of what we
covered last time
now
one question that may come up is well so
right now this we have this black box
neural network that's representing
um
that's representing this kind of
learning process right that's taking a
training data set and outputting the
weights of another neural network
and there might be other ways that we
can represent this process and instead
of treating it as this kind of black box
inference procedure we could instead
treat it as an optimization procedure
and in many ways this is kind of the
main idea behind optimization based meta
learning
so if you take the black box
adaptation approach if you want to make
it optimization based what you can
simply do is replace the neural network
that produces phi i with something that
looks more like an optimization process
and then metal learn all the free
parameters of that optimization process
such as the initialization the learning
rate or other
other ways that you might kind of tweak
this this optimization
so kind of the key idea is to embed an
optimization inside this inner learning
process
now why might this make sense in
comparison to a black box adaptation
approach
well
so one way to look at this is actually
from the perspective of fine tuning and
transfer learning
so one thing that we saw before with
fine tuning was that if you
uh start with a set of pre-trained
parameters and fine-tune
this is quite effective especially when
you have a fairly kind of
sizable number of training examples that
you're fine-tuning on
but this is less effective with very
small data sets
and so
essentially what's the question that
optimization based metal learning
algorithms try to seek to answer is well
what if instead of
initializing from a set of pre-trained
parameters initialized on the imagenet
for example what if we explicitly
optimized for a set of pre-trained
parameters
and maybe also the learning rate or
other aspects of this fine-tuning
process
so that we can generalize effectively
with a small number of examples
um and so in particular one
instantiation of this which is the
called the model agnostic metal learning
algorithm
it tries to be able to do fine tuning at
test time
and it tries to find a set of
pre-trained parameters such that
fine-tuning generalizes well with a
small amount of data
and the way this optimization looks like
is we take the fine-tuning process
uh we say okay we want this fine
sheeting process to generalize well with
a small training data set so we'll feed
in a small training data set and then
evaluate fine tuning on new held out
data points
in our
task test set
and then we'll optimize for the
initialization for theta
such that this one or a few steps of
fine-tuning
generalizes well to these new data
points
and then of course we do this
optimization across all of the tasks in
our meta training set
so the key idea here is we're
essentially going to be trying to learn
a parameter vector theta that can
transfer to all of the tasks in our meta
training data set with a few steps of
fine tuning
this equation shows one gradient step in
practice it could just be one or it
could be a few or a handful
although as you kind of increase the
number of gradient steps it gets a
little bit
this kind of optimization problem gets a
little bit more
unwieldy
okay so this is kind of the
uh
kind of a basic version of an
optimization based because the gist of
an optimization based meta learner in
the sense that it's kind of
embedding this optimization inside
the process in order to get
this will give you something that looks
like
buy eye basically fine-tuning will get
you phi eye and then you're optimizing
405 i such that it generalizes on the
test set
um and then one way that you could view
this process
more visually is say theta is the
parameter vector that you're meta
learning
and phi i star is the optimal parameter
vector for all of your meta training
tasks
then in some sense you could view the
meta learning process as this thick
black line here
where when you're at this point during
the metatrading process if you take a
gradient step with respect to test three
you're quite far from the optimum for
task three
um and likewise kind of for the other
tasks if you take a single gradient set
for task two you're quite far from the
optimum and likewise for task one
whereas by the time you get to the end
of the metatrading process if you take a
gradient step with this vector task 3
you're much closer and likewise for all
of the other tasks
so this is kind of a cartoon diagram to
give some intuition for
what this sort of meta training
algorithm might be doing
okay so there's a question from in the
chat
what we need to calculate the double
derivatives of the loss for the
optimization does this slow down the
algorithm
uh
yes we will have to compute the second
derivatives
and we'll get to this in on the next
slide basically
yeah and then he's asking why do we only
do one step of gradient descent rather
than multiple steps
so
uh you can just you can absolutely
implement this with multiple steps uh
and it's actually pretty common to
implement it with multiple gradient
steps i'm ready it only is a single step
here for now because that's simpler
notationally it takes a little bit more
screen space to write down multiple
steps
um if you want to do a very large number
of gradient steps then it also as i
mentioned before it gets very
computationally expensive and so
typically
you will do around like five gradient
steps um or fewer than that maybe ten um
there are some works that go beyond that
as well but in practice you can get the
you can get actually pretty far with
only a few gradient steps
do you have a question
um yeah so are you basically the way
you're training with are you sort of
trying to get a set of parameters
that you initialize
uh directly with those parameters given
uh uh test task
and you want to you and the way and then
what you want to do is you want those
parameters to be so good that when you
initialize with them you can do
like
like a few shots future optimization and
then get a good position
yeah exactly so the goal of theta is to
basically find a set of pre-trained
parameters that are so good that
even with a few steps of grain descent
on a small data set you can generalize
well
from those examples
is asking do you compute the gradient on
a batch or sample mini batches so let's
actually go to
the next slide to
to answer this so
this is what's called a model agnostic
metal learning algorithm or mammal for
short
um in the sense that it's gnostic like
the model architecture doesn't really
play a role anywhere in here and so
really any architecture should be able
to work for this
or any loss function as long as the
architecture and the loss function are
amenable to this form of gradient based
optimization
so in terms of what this looks like as
an algorithm so i talked just about the
objective on the previous slides how to
actually optimize this objective in an
algorithm
so we can take the same algorithm from
the black box approach
and there's just a few things that we'll
change so first we'll sample a mini
batch of tasks
we'll sample disjoint data sets dtrain
and detest
then instead of computing
the parameters from just with this
neural network we're instead going to
compute these parameters by
fine-tuning from our current
meta parameters
and then when we update
the model um we're going to use
basically the same update as before
where uh we're going to back propagate
through this fine tuning process to the
initialization
um in order to update our metaprams
as was mentioned by uh by div this
actually does bring up second order
derivatives
um
and
i guess i'll talk about that in a second
first i want to ask answer um a question
what's your question
um yeah so i think i'm still struggling
to understand the intuition
uh because what we are doing here is
that we're taking the of the d train for
a task um and even though we take just
small gradient steps uh we are updating
the uh the entire theta which means like
all the parameters
so so why does it work um like always uh
or in all cases is is isn't there
potential for like uh some large
perturbations uh because of some tasks
yeah so i guess a few thoughts here one
is that the
this alpha parameter um
you could either have it be a hyper this
is kind of the learning rate of the fine
tuning process you can either have it be
a hyper parameter or have it be learned
um although in many cases it's just a
hyper parameter and you can actually set
this to be pretty large so that it's
actually taking pretty large gradient
steps on your few shot data set
now one thing you might be worried about
is you might overfit to this really
small data set especially if you're
taking very large steps
however with this optimization you're
kind of explicitly optimizing for a
point in the parameter space
that won't lead to overfitting when you
take a few gradient steps on a small
data set
so kind of by nature of actually
optimizing explicitly for
the kind of region of parameter space
that you're in and for this these
initial features
you can
avoid these problems in principle
does that answer your question
oh yeah yeah i think that that makes
sense um to do an extent but i'm just
wondering that uh with this not um
like the prior task
would we not lose accuracy on them um as
we start to do this on future tasks
um right so when we do this on new tasks
at test time we need to assume that
those tasks are still somewhat similar
to the tasks that we saw during meta
training
and specifically they need to be from
the same distribution as the tasks that
we saw during metatrading
and if we have enough tasks and and the
tasks that we see at test time are in
that same distribution then we can
expect it to work well for those tasks
if you get to give it a completely
unrelated house that isn't from that
distribution then
um you may not expect it to generalize
as well
okay thanks
great and then i also saw that there was
a question in the chat about what is phi
i again um so
in this case i'm using phi i to denote
the just the kind of
the pr up the fine tuning parameters as
a result of fine tuning from theta on
the fu shot data set di train
on the previous slide i also mentioned i
also had a notation for phi i star and
this was the optimal parameter vectors
for for that task um
just because as an illustrative diagram
okay
do you have a question
yes so
i'm also having a bit of trouble
understanding
[Music]
so phi i within step three is
a copy of theta and then we try to
optimize that using test and then
then we optimize the actual theta
so phi i is the result of running
gradient descent on theta
so after you run um
after you basically so theta is your
kind of meta parameters it's the initial
parameters that you're uh that you're
learning throughout the meta training
process and then phi i is a
is the result of taking multiple
gradient steps on theta starting from
theta on your training data set for that
task
but we are dating theta in step four
right so in step three we are optimizing
a copy of theta right
is that how to interpret it yeah so yeah
so in step three you're optimizing a
copy of theta and a question that was
also asked in the chat is do we
reinitialize theta for each i and that's
correct so we're always going to be
starting fine tuning
from this set of initial parameters
theta we're not going to be starting it
from where we had fine tuned to last
great
yeah so the training data here refers to
like samples from multiple tasks and not
a single task
so d train i corresponds to the training
data for a single task so you sample a
task here
um then you stamp then you kind of split
the data for that task into a train set
and a test set
um these are both from the same task
then you run fine-tuning on data from
that task and
uh
measure how well the fine-tuned
parameters generalized to new data from
that task and then you update your meta
parameters
as well
right
i'm just trying to understand how is
this different from
uh let's say transfer learning where you
would train you've taken a model screen
on imagenet
yeah so the way that this is different
from like
from transfer learning and fine tuning
is that in transfer learning and fine
tuning you optimize your data your
initial parameters by training on
treating kind of directly on a previous
task or previous set of tasks
basically trying to
um
let's see
i'm
so what transfer learning would try to
do is it would say kind of
um
theta and it
equals basically
min of theta
of
l of theta
um
d i
and maybe you're do maybe you're kind of
uh
this is what transfer learning is doing
i'll call it tl
basically it's going to try to find an
initial parameter such that you minimize
your loss on your set of training tasks
and then at test time you fine-tune this
data init on other things
and then what this is doing
which is a bit different is it's
learning a set
of initial parameters such that
um
optimize over tasks uh basically you
just replace
uh
theta with phi i
and this is on the test set for task i
where phi i equals the fine-tuned
version
of
um
of this so the key difference is that in
transfer learning you would basically be
optimizing just so that theta does well
on all of your tasks and what this is
doing is optimizing such that when you
fine tune from theta you do well on your
tasks
does that answer your
question yeah it does thanks
great
uh yeah uh this might be something
you're gonna um address later in the
lecture but i was wondering if there are
any theoretical guarantees
of
um i mean i guess like the optimization
or this approach in general
yeah so we'll talk a bit about
theoretically what the expressive power
of this meta-learner is
um there is also some work on that
studies basically the theoretical
guarantees of whether
this meta learning process will
actually
give you the optimum um and i won't
actually cover that in the lecture but
if you're interested in that maybe make
a post on piazza and i can send some
pointer references
okay thank you
so my question is like in step three we
are learning this task specific
parameter by taking one variance from
this global theta which is common common
corner
so when we're doing step four the
gradient loss again
[Music]
how many gradient steps would take a
step forward
[Music]
yeah so
when we update it using um
in this fourth step when we're updating
the meta parameters uh typically you
just run one gradient step on
theta uh
and in order to compute this
gradient right here you need a kind of a
prerequisite you need to compute phi i
um so you basically alternate between
computing phi i and then computing the
gradient of your meta parameters
[Music]
yes um
although here you could also run it's
pretty common to also run more than one
gradient step for this one um it's this
can be a few gradient steps here you
really want this to be just a single
gradient step because it's only
pertinent to this uh this value of pi
directly initialized
uh your knowledge of your one section
without doing any
um
algorithms
you can see the loss of the past
innocence
um and
to update the um
graphics data and in the optimization
based approach
um
you will add additional freedom to send
styles to the
that's close so
the
black box model
um that's shown
right here this is kind of
having a neural network
basically represent the optimization
itself it's outputting
phi i directly
whereas in the optimization based
approach
the meta parameters correspond to the
initialization and to get phi i the task
specific parameters you are running an
optimization
there's kind of no no optimization um
that happens you just run you just take
your neural network and run it forward
whereas in the optimization based metal
learner you're running this optimization
of your actual network exactly in the
optimization basics
you want to take into account
um
basically yes although in the
optimization-based approach basically
you're in this case you're just off
you're optimizing the initial parameters
and then the way that you get the
gradients are by
taking the actual gradient
like we are
setting phi i as a function of theta and
d
[Music]
yeah so they're both um they're both
kind of a function of data and the
training data uh one is that
one of them is using a neural network to
produce phyii and one of them is using
an optimization to produce phyii
okay
um yeah i was wondering if you mentioned
the second order directives i was trying
to think through if you have multiple
gradient steps on step three
um would that like keep nesting
and get like higher and higher order
so i might be picturing something wrong
yeah that's a great question and i was
actually planning to talk about that
next so that's let's actually talk about
that so
there's two questions that come up here
one is we have second order derivatives
does that mean that we need to compute
the full hessian uh
and if we did that would be a pretty big
problem because if we have a really huge
vector of parameters then the hessian is
going to be
a matrix that is has a dimensionality of
the size of your parameters by the size
of your parameters
and the second is that if we take more
than one inner gradient step here
do we actually have third third and
fourth order derivatives when you take
more intergradient steps
um does anyone have any
guesses as to the answer of these
questions before i kind of go through
some of the math
so there's one guess which is that maybe
we only need the diagonal of the hessian
which isn't quite correct
yeah so she says maybe we only have to
compute the hessian vector products
which which will turn out to be correct
and we'll go through why that's the case
so
um so as we talked about before we can
basically view
um
we have this kind of update procedure
that takes as input a
network um a set of parameters
and a training data set and in the
mammal case this update procedure might
be something like
one gradient descent step
on your training law starting from your
metatrain parameters
and
uh it can also be multiple integrated
steps but we'll start with the case
where it's just one integrating step
and then
our
meta objective
is something like
actually i'm gonna
write this in my lap so the
the meta objective is something like min
over theta of l of phi i
comma
g trait or sorry this is g test i
so this is our kind of the objective
with regard to our metaparameter's data
and this is equal to
the min over theta
of
l
f theta d train i
comma
d test i
um and i'm just using f here as
shorthand for the the gradient step
um it's going to be helpful to have that
shorthand in like for the next step
so in order to optimize this meta
objective
um
what does our meta optimization look
like so we want to compute the gradient
with regard to
our parameters theta in order to
optimize this objective
um one side note is that i'm going to
use d
d d
x or whatever's to be the
total derivative and the gradient
uh with regard to
x as
the partial derivative just as kind of
to be able to split apart the
notation so in order to do this this
meta optimization we need to compute the
um the derivative
of
our objective right
and so the first question is do we have
to compute the full hessian in order to
compute this derivative do we have to
actually like construct that entire
question or do we only need hessian
vector products
so to do that we'll expand out what this
this derivative looks like so to do that
we can
first take the chain rule and say
this derivative is equal to
um
the gradient of this loss with respect
to
phi i times the derivative of
a phi i with respect to theta
so this is equal to
first the
partial derivative
um
of
phi
r
evaluated at five bar
equals
phi i um where this kind of equals
f of theta comma d train
so this is the derivative of the first
term with respect to phi i and then we
also will have a term that looks like
d phi i
d theta
um
cool so this is uh one the first kind of
expansion of the gradient
now if we want to consider what these
for what these two terms look like this
first term
is going to be a row vector because
l is a scalar function
and then the second term is going to be
a matrix
um
and basically the way that you get this
row vector is you can get this row
vector just by taking a single backward
pass through the network so you just
evaluate the loss at
phi i and then run a backward pass to
get the gradient at phi i so this is
basically just like one backward pass
now what is what about the second term
so
uh
maybe let's just separately look at this
second term
so
the second term
is
so we know that phi i is equal to
one
gradient step
and so if we want to compute the
derivative of the second term with
respect to theta what we're going to get
is g phi i
d theta equals
the identity
oh sorry i should have um
this should actually technically be a
total derivative
um
what we'll get is something like the
identity minus alpha times
g squared d theta squared
of
l of theta d train
so this term right here this is the
hessian right
um let's call this
h and let's call
this
row vector r
then what we get is that this the
gradient with respect to theta is equal
to
um
r
times
identity
minus alpha
r times the hessian
uh and so the way that we got that is we
just basically plugged in
this
term and uh in for the matrix right here
and we get this and the result of this
is that this means that we only have to
do the hessian vector product between
the row vector and the hessian and we
don't need to worry about actually
computing the full question
okay
any questions on
that
do you have a question on this
hi so um why is it the case that i mean
um why why do you save anything we do
this type of
uh
yeah so there are efficient ways to
compute um
hessian vector products without having
to construct the full session um
i guess i
i don't want to get into that too much
uh but the kind of the the main takeaway
is that
there are basically ways to compute the
assessment vector product without
actually having to construct the full
hessian
in memory
um
yeah and if you're interested in kind of
learning more about some of those
techniques then we could also post some
resources on kretsa
also possible that matt johnson will go
into some of those techniques um
in the lecture on monday
okay and then there's one more thing
that we talked about before which is
you're wondering um
if we
take more than one inner gradient step
um
do we get
third order derivatives and fourth order
derivatives so
this is kind of a simple extension on
top of what we just showed so instead of
saying
that
phi i equals one gradient step if we say
that phi i
equals two gradient steps then it equals
theta minus
alpha grad theta l of d train and then
when we take the second gradient step
we're going to take that second gradient
step starting from the result of this
first gradient step so we'll call this
theta prime and then the next gradient
step will be at theta prime
l of theta prime
d train
so this is
uh what phi i equals to if we have
um
if we run two gradient steps
and
what we get um if we want to compute
basically
so the place where the hessian comes
into again here is this matrix right
here and so
what we're interested in is if we
compute d phi d theta
does this give us the hessian or does
this give us a higher order terms
so
um what you get is if you take this phi
i on the left and you compute the
derivative with respect to theta then
you get something like
uh the identity matrix for theta
minus alpha times
the
uh
pattern like we had before
l theta d train
and then the
for the second term we get minus alpha
um
and then we actually get so we're in
this case we're taking the derivative of
this term
evaluated at theta and so we're going to
going to need to apply the chain rule
again
and what you get if you do this is you
get
um
another second derivative
this time actually at theta prime
um
uh l of theta prime
d train
evaluated at
theta prime
times
d theta prime d theta uh so the main
takeaway here is that the
basically even if you have two
intergradient steps the highest order
term that you get is still only going to
be second derivatives
and the key idea is that the um
the key idea is
the reason why this is the case is that
when you take this second inner gradient
step you take it at theta prime not at
theta uh if you were taking it at theta
um
then you would well
then basically these terms would combine
um
but because we're taking it at theta
prime
we
basically will not get higher order
gradients
yeah and then i was asking is it typical
to take multiple gradient steps on the
same d train um so one thing you could
do here is instead of running basically
batch gradient descent on your small
train set you could run sgd where you
basically like run one ingredient step
on the first data point one greater step
on the second data point and so forth
when we're in the fu shot learning
setting you typically
will
um typically breaking up the
really small data set that you have into
even finer data sets will lead to kind
of fairly high variance gradients
and so typically at least in my
experience i found it most helpful to
run multiple gradient steps on the same
training data set so that you get
the least noise in your gradient
okay
um any questions on
that there's actually one more question
from about how do we get uh d theta
prime d theta um that's basically the
computation that we did
up here
um
it's yeah the same as that computation
he's asking are these higher order
differentiation supported by deep
learning frameworks uh yes so both uh
both tensorflow and high torch
and jacks support these second order
taking basically second derivatives with
regard to your network
um
yeah some
especially tensorflow especially the
more developed ones um in the past
uh
some of them have been a little bit
shakier with regards to second
derivatives but i think that both of
those both tensorflow and pytorch are
developed enough to
uh support these and basically compute
all these derivatives for you uh this is
mostly just an exercise to understand
exactly what's happening under the hood
uh when you actually go about
implementing these algorithms you don't
actually have to understand
um these calculations for better or for
worse i think i still think it's helpful
to understand them to know that you
don't have to compute this question and
to know that um you don't get third over
derivatives
but in practice it's actually fairly
convenient that we don't have to worry
about actually computing these manually
when implementing them
okay so
that's the gist of optimization based my
learning
so now let's talk a bit about
how optimization based my learners and
black box my learners
are
how they kind of compare conceptually
what are the benefits of one versus the
other
so
in black box adaptation there's this
general form
basically having a neural network take
as input a training data set and maybe
also a test input and produce an output
uh and maybe somewhere in the middle
here you may also have
um
some
supply
i or you can extract that away
now um in model agnostic metal learning
you can actually also view the same kind
of general form
uh but where
you have this phi eye that is competed
with grade 8 and then you process your
test inputs with that network
um so in some ways actually mammal can
be viewed
as the same sort of computation graph
where you're taking as input a training
data set and a test input but there's
this gradient operator that's embedded
inside that computation graph
and i think that this view is is useful
for thinking about how these two methods
compare in many ways they're both
optimized for doing the same exact thing
it's just that mammal has this structure
of an optimization built inside of it so
that you can expect it to
um to essentially still descend on the
objective that you care about at least
on the train dataset
now it's worth noting that you can mix
and match components of this computation
graph uh
and this
view of things is helpful for
understanding how you might do that
um so one thing that you could do for
example is you could learn the
initialization and you could also
um instead of using the actual gradient
you could replace the gradient update
with a large network
that looks something like this where you
learn data and you also learn this
network that takes as input the gradient
and modifies it in some way
this was done in this paper by sachin
ravi and people bar shell in 2017 and
actually precedes the the mammal
algorithm that we've covered
um and also this computation group craft
view of metal learning will come back
again in a couple lectures when we are
also comparing and thinking about a
third kind of membrane object
now one thing that's maybe we're
thinking about in terms of metal
learning algorithms is
how these methods might do if you're on
tasks that are a bit different from what
you saw during training
so if you're
given a task that's kind of out of
distribution from what you saw during
the mediterranean process
um
mammal will still be running fine tuning
or be running gradient descent on that
held out task
and so we can still expect it to do
something reasonable
when provided this out of distribution
data
whereas if you feed that out of
distribution data into the black box
neural network you can't really you
don't really know exactly what it will
do with that data it might not
generalize well
we can actually empirically
uh
consider this
consider this exercise of looking at how
these methods do on extrapolated tests
and what we'll do is we'll compare
mammal to
two forms of black box metal learners
one is called snail and one is called
meta networks
um they're basically just different
kinds of memory based neural networks
that process data with a single network
um and we look at the omniglot task and
we'll construct the
we'll construct different tasks and
we'll construct actually out of
distribution tasks by skewing
the digits and also by scaling the
digits
and what we find is
on each of these cases we're looking at
the performance as you move
away from the distribution that things
were trained on
um of course as you move from the like
all these algorithms we're kind of
trained on this distribution and they
they all do pretty well when
you are testing on what they're trained
on
but when you move away from
the manifold of tasks that what they are
trained on we see that all of them
degrade
but we see that mammal degrades the
least out of the three
methods
and this is kind of what we would expect
because we're fine tuning on these out
of distribution tests you can still
expect them to do something reasonable
when you're fine-tuning
um in contrast to passing this these
distribution data points into
uh black box neural network
okay
any questions on this experiment
here by one shot do you mean that you're
just doing one um gradient step update
to get fly from data
um i actually can't remember how many
gradient steps were used uh by one shot
learning i mean that there's one example
per
uh
sorry yeah one example per class in the
classification process
[Music]
right so the way this experiment was
done is it was mediterranean on standard
omniglot and then it met a test time we
either gave it a training data set that
had
um
digits that
were kind of normal or we gave it a
a task and a meditating data set that
has skewed digits or scale digits
so the
the outer distribution tests are only
happening at meta test time and it's
reflected both in the transact and the
test set of that meta test task
yeah so
uh during this matter test time so we
are again optimizing right so how many
steps we're doing like just one step of
inner and outer reading or like multiple
yeah that's a big question so with
mammal based algorithms um
you want to the number of gradients
fine-tuning steps that you run at
meta-test time you want to be at least
as large as the number of gradients
intergradient steps that you use during
metatrading although in practice you can
also run more gradient steps if you find
that you haven't converged on the
um if you find that your kind of
training accuracy hasn't converged that
meta test time
[Music]
i guess typically you don't need to run
that much so you'll kind of typically
meta train with one or a few gradient
steps and then at meta test time you
might run
um you might run like up to 20 gradient
steps but typically because these
these in future learning because your
training data sets are so small you
converge very quickly
uh have a question like is there any
inside why like
there's a skew in the dataset the drop
in performance is very low like
10 percent but like
for the scaling the drop is quite high
like 20 percent or something
yeah so i wouldn't necessarily think
think that like
i wouldn't necessarily say that like
this skew is comparable to this scale
like you could skew the data even more
and you would probably expect to see a
even larger drop in performance um i
think that just the scale that's
considered here is probably a bit more
drastic than this year that's considered
yeah so in beta test time we
start from our theta parameters and then
we run fine tuning on our training data
set from there and then at the end of
fine tuning we get a set of parameters
that we evaluate uh
accuracy on
so this is to get the fire
yeah okay
okay
sounds good
i was asking in mammal does the
initialization of theta matter a lot if
so what was the initialization for
mammal here
so uh the
let's go back to the algorithm real
quick so
um i guess there's kind of a step zero
here which is to
like take an initialization for theta
and then
uh
at the end of this you'll get some kind
of set of initial parameters theta that
are good
uh and in general this initialization
here
isn't super important typically we just
use like random initialization it's
about as important as uh initial
parameters are in general with deep
learning
um
and then of course the final
initialization that you get for meta
test time is is very important uh and
that's exactly what mammal is optimizing
for
i was asking how much worse does
multitask learning plus fine tuning do
on these auto distribution tasks so we
didn't actually
evaluate that here but we would also
expect
multi-task learning and fine-tuning
to
be
more robust to these other distribution
tasks in comparison to things like snail
and
meta networks
yeah but we don't have i don't have any
results on this specific that's a
specific evaluation
okay now we get this nice structure of
building an optimization into
our metal learner and the structure
allows us to potentially generalize
better to extrapolated tasks
but one downside is well maybe the
structure means that we can't express as
many learning procedures
so
we know that a black box adaptation
procedure if this neural network
is
large enough then you can represent any
learning procedure
in the sense that neural networks are
universal function approximators but we
don't know if that same statement is
true for mammal we don't know that if
our network is big enough
whether it will be able to represent
um any learning procedure when it has
this gradient operator inside the
computation graph
and so we actually studied this question
and it turns out that you can
theoretically show that if you have a
sufficiently deep network then
this mammal function can approximate any
function of the training data set
and the test data point
um under a few assumptions
uh and the assumptions are fairly fairly
mild the first is that you have to have
a non-zero learning rate uh this makes
sense
um
the second assumption is is pretty
important this is that the loss function
gradient cannot lose information about
the label
um and then the third assumption is that
the data points in your training data
set have to be unique and this is also
often true in practice
and the intuition behind this result is
that if you view mammal as the
computation graph that we talked about
before where there's a gradient operator
in the middle
as long as that gradient operator
doesn't um doesn't kind of discard
information about your data points in
your training data set
then you
um then you can also still represent
that computation graph can still
represent
any learning procedure
uh and well why is this important or
interesting um does this mean that this
means that mammal has the benefit of
inductive bias without losing uh the
expressive power that you get from black
box adaptation approaches
um
okay cool
so now i want to talk a bit about
challenges and some of the challenges
that come up with this class of
approaches and some of the solutions
that people have come up with
so one challenge is
that
we have this bi-level optimization and
it says that we're embedding gradient
descent inside another gradient percent
optimization
and this can exhibit some instabilities
um and so there are a few ideas that you
could do
to try to mitigate this
one is to try to automatically learn
your inner learning rate alpha um
or tune your up your audio learning rate
in order to
uh not have to worry too much about
tuning either of these manually
uh in practice i do i have found that
like the inner learning rate is really
important for getting things to work
well and the outer learning rate in
practice i found that adam works well
and to be out of integrate for you but
there are also some prior works that
i've looked at tuning that outer
learning rate automatically
another idea is to only optimize a
subset of the parameters in the inner
loop
and this can be a little bit lighter of
an optimization in the inner loop and
reduce some of the instabilities
um the third idea is to decouple the
inner learning rate and the bot form
statistics for each gradient to some
stuff so that if you're running one
gradient descent step and another
gradient descent step
and the third one you have different
learning rates and different batch forms
statistics for each step of that inner
optimization
this can also make the optimization a
bit more flexible
um
you can also introduce some context
variables to increase the expressive
power
um
i guess the general takeaway that i'd
like to get across here is that there's
a range of fairly simple tricks that can
help the optimization fairly
significantly um even the vanilla
algorithm works pretty well uh but there
are various number of tricks that can be
helpful
okay um it looks like there's a question
from
i'm pushing the last slide
yeah
but i can explain what do you mean by
those functions
information about the label
what does it
yeah so what this means is that um
basically when you take the gradient of
um
a loss function
we
we're passing in the training data set
here and
depending on your choice of loss
function
uh
we want to be able to recover the labels
of the training data set from the
gradient
um and there are some i guess some
examples of this is if you have an l1
loss function
then the gradient is just uh
it's like
one or negative one essentially
uh and this will lose information
because depending like basically how
incorrect you are
uh
doesn't really affect can
if you're incorrect but you don't know
like how incorrect you are um that
doesn't really affect
the gradient of like an l1 loss function
whereas if you have something more like
mean squared error or cross entropy the
gradient is actually much more
much more informative about the label
uh and you can if you actually write out
the gradient it's possible to actually
recover the full grade the full label
information from that gradient if you
know the model's prediction
does that answer your question
sorry what did you say so basically
margins also will also be
yeah so the o1 loss and the margin loss
will will also be losing information
things like l2
and cross-entropy loss will not lose
information
um that isn't to say that you can use
all of these loss functions in practice
with mammal and people who have been
successful using these loss functions
um
it's just a kind of a criterion for
proving this result um and you don't
really need this result to hold true for
um
for most learning procedures that you
care about in practice
okay
so let's talk about two more challenges
so one challenge one more challenge and
this is actually perhaps one of the most
important challenges is that if you have
a lot of inner gradient steps
then
back propagating through those inner
gradient steps can actually be pretty
compute intensive and pretty memory
intensive because you typically have to
store
all the iterates of that inner
optimization and then back propagate all
the way through it
there have been a few approaches for
trying to tackle this challenge and i'll
highlight three of them
so the first is that instead of trying
to back propagate through that
optimization path from theta to phi i
you can crudely approximate this
jacobian as the identity function
and basically assume that um
that things that phi i look like
things at theta
um
this is a very crude approximation uh
in practice this jacobian is actually
nowhere near identity from what i found
uh although somewhat surprisingly this
actually does work for
simple few shot learning problems um
anecdotally i found that this doesn't
work well for more complex meta learning
problems um
so your mileage may vary um this is kind
of known as first order mammal and
there's also the reptile algorithm that
does something fairly similar to this
approximation as well
um it's called first order mammal in the
sense that you don't actually need
second order gradients if you make this
approximation
uh and this kind of relates to the
calculations that we were doing earlier
as well
okay
um another idea is to only optimize the
last layer of the weights
in your
inner optimization
so before we were saying that we were
going to fine tune all of the weights in
the network but one thing you could do
is just fine tune the last layer
and there are a number of approaches
that have done this where they basically
optimize both for
four set of features such that when you
optimize
um on top of that with logistic
regression ridge regression or support
vector machine you generalize well with
a small amount of data
and one of the things that's pretty cool
about these kinds of approaches is that
it can actually um
the
uh
when you do this kind of rid regression
and logistic regression as well as a
support vector machine this leads to
either a closed form optimization or a
convex optimization in the inner loop
and there are kind of various other
techniques for actually differentiating
through these closed form or convex
optimizations that make it
a lot
more efficient in practice
um so if you're in a setting where kind
of optimizing just the last layer
will kind of be expected to work well
then um this is a very reasonable
approach if you think that you may need
to fine-tune much deeper than that then
of course this won't be uh quite as
helpful
now the last idea is there's also a way
to derive the meta gradient using what's
called the implicit function theorem
and it basically allows you to compute
d phi i
d theta without actually having to back
propagate through the
optimization path
um which is pretty cool
uh for time i'm not going to go through
the details of this but if you want to
see a derivation of how this works you
can check out the lecture from last year
okay um and this kind of leads to some
nice memory and computation tradeoffs
where basically as you increase the
number of ingredients descent steps
the
uh basically the memory cost is
completely constant as you increase the
number of gradient to some steps and the
computation cost uh is
increases more slowly if you do this in
comparison to back propagating through
the optimization
cool so
it's asking in the chat what's the
difference between phi and theta so
um
basically in the context of optimization
based metal learning we're saying that
phi i
is basically the result of running
fine tuning
starting initialized at theta so theta
is the initialization of fine tuning and
phi i is the result of fine-tuning i'm
using a subscript i to denote that this
fine-tuning process
uh takes as input a data set
uh d-train that's specific to toxici
um so in some ways theta is the meta
parameters and phi i is the
task-specific parameters that have been
fine-tuned for that test
okay
um yeah and then one other cool thing
about this is this also allows for
second order optimizers in the inner
loop because you don't have to back
propagate through those second order
optimizers which would lead to third
order optimization
um and this has led to some good
performance
okay
cool
um and then the last challenge that i'd
like to mention is that uh some of the
the architecture that works well for
optimization based metal learner metal
learning isn't always the same as
architectures that work for deep
learning
uh and
one uh work has actually combined
neural architecture research with mammal
to try to find an architecture that
works well with mammal
uh and they found that
fairly non-standard architectures that
are
very deep and narrow
actually led to pretty large gains in
performance on something like mini
imagenet
um in comparison to using a more
standard architecture
okay
cool so
to summarize optimization-based
adaptation and meta-learning uh the kind
of the key idea is to acquire phi i
through an optimization rather than
through a neural network directly
and this involves constructing a
bi-level optimization problem
there are a number of benefits to this
approach so you get kind of this
positive inductive bias at the start of
metal learning because you're already
going to be fine-tuning which is already
a reasonable way to transfer to a new
task
and then from there you're just going to
be improving upon the initialization or
the learning rate or other aspects of
the optimization
uh as we saw it tends to extrapolate
better than block box metal learners
it's also maximally expressive if you
have a sufficiently large network
and it's model agnostic in the sense
that it should be fairly straightforward
to combine with different architectures
uh the downsides is that it typically
requires a second order optimization
uh and it's usually more compute and
memory intensive than block box metal
learning approaches
uh uh questions you illustrate again
what does this positive inductor pass me
[Music]
yeah so what i mean by positive
inductive bias is just the sense that
you're building an optimization into the
medliner so you already have um
you're already kind of starting from
this optimization that you know will do
somewhat reasonably
and it says that fine tuning does
somewhat reasonably when you have data
from a new task
whereas if you just have a black box
neural network that doesn't know
anything about optimization that it
doesn't have that
what i'm calling inductive bias
[Music]
of your most recent updated parameter
with respect to the parameters itself
um so that parameter itself contains its
history and so it contains previous
updates
um
how is how is optimization taking cookie
of this time different from a
conventional sgd when you just update a
category gradient of a parameter that's
yeah so the i guess in some ways this is
similar to what i was mentioning with
regard to transfer learning
where
um
where transfer learning is doing
something like basically min
over theta of
l of theta d train whereas something
like this metal learning approach
is doing min of l of
theta minus alpha grad theta
d train
um
in some ways you can like this
optimization
you're still going to be doing this
optimization with an sgd approach
so that kind of outer optimization is
just the same as vanilla sgd
what's just a little bit different is
that you have this you have this
gradient operator inside of your
objective
and so you need to be thinking about
actually this second order optimization
because you need to back propagate um
through a gradient step itself
uh but if you take kind of the
computation graph view of things and
just view this gradient operator as
being part of your computation graph
then there are a lot of
when you're similarities learning
theta is nothing but you know theta
prime minus alpha
delta
uh can you repeat that
yeah so in the transfer
top level the equation is actually
theta l
theorem but theta is nothing but just
the previous equation of theta so theta
figures minus alpha times
yes okay one thing that's different is
that so i see what your point so
basically this is like theta at
iteration i and theta in iteration i
is equal to
basically
theta at iteration i minus 1 minus a
gradient step basically
um
one thing that's different here is that
it's so
in sgd you don't really keep track
you're taking kind of the
the partial derivative at theta i you're
not kind of really keeping track of how
that is a function of theta i minus one
whereas here you when you do this you
need to actually
um back propagate through this gradient
step right here
into your previous value of theta and
optimize kind of your previous value of
theta um
the initialization such that a gradient
step gives you good performance
um and so this affects the way that you
implement these algorithms um because
you can't just say we're going to take a
gradient step and then optimize
like and then actually kind of do like
assign your parameters to have that
value and then take a gradient step
again
um in many ways it's kind of the
difference between a total derivative
and a partial derivative um
is
um so
this so there's a sum over i here and
this is what i call the inner step
and then the kind of
things that are used to optimize this is
called the outer step uh you need to
compute the inner step for multiple
different tasks and then once you do
that you'll need to compute the outer
step on each of those tasks as well and
then average
the outer step is computed
like when you
when you compute the gradient here that
gradient will kind of can go inside the
sum here and you will be computing the
great kind of the meta gradient for each
of your tasks
and then
averaging hi uh could you explain like
why um the memo is easy to like
uh combine with like different modes
architecture perspective of the theta we
still need architecture to like
yeah i guess when i say that i just mean
that basically all of these equations
are only having to do with the
parameters of your model and don't
really prescribe anything about the
architecture of that model um whereas
with a black box approach you need to
figure out how to
combine whatever architecture you like
to process data
with an architecture that can process
like multiple data points
that said this optimization will become
more difficult if computing gradients
for that architecture are more difficult
like if you have a recurrent neural
network then mammal can be a bit more
tricky to combine with our current
neural network because you have to kind
of back propagate gradients through time
through that recurrent network
okay for the sake of time i'm gonna go
through this case study and then i'll
try to answer additional questions at
the end at 2 20.
so
uh this case study was looking at how we
could use med learning for a few shot
land cover classification uh
which is a pretty cool application
and this was actually a pretty recent
paper that was at the earth vision
workshop at cvpr this year
and if you're interested the link to the
paper is also right here which you can
find in the slides
so the problem that they're looking at
is trying to map land covering from
satellite images
and
they looked at a few different data sets
and this is basically what the problem
looks like you have some satellite
imagery
that looks like these images here
and your goal is to output something
like
these segmentation
uh the first data set is a lower
resolution data set where you basically
say like within a certain region what is
kind of the predominant uh
use of that land whereas this uh this
data set is much more fine-grained and
different categories of land covering
include urban agricultural rangeland
forest water barren
and unknown
and if we can successfully kind of
classify land covering then this may
have applications in global herbal urban
planning when you're figuring out
actually
how to use land in different ways uh
climate change research and potentially
other
earth science applications
now what are some of the challenges that
come up here so
first labeling data is really expensive
uh you have to label kind of individual
pixels or in this case
label something that's a little bit
lower resolution but you still have to
go through maps and hand label these
things
and also different regions look very
different and have different land use
proportions
so we have kind of a lot of distribution
shift both in like p of x both in the
image distribution as well as in p of y
which is the kind of use of those
different pieces of land
so for example if you look at kind of
croplands from four different countries
from mali brazil poland and angola we
see pretty substantial differences
between the images from these countries
so the way that they framed this as a
metal earning problem was different
tasks corresponded to different regions
of the world such as these four regions
for example
and their goal is to be able to segment
or classify images from a new region
with a small amount of data from that
region
by leveraging the data from the other
regions
so essentially they took kind of the the
mammal algorithm and we're trying to
learn an initialization such that you
could quickly fine-tune that model to
accurately classify
the satellite images in different
regions of the world
okay
and then kind of more specifically how
they frame this as a better learning
problem so they did this a little bit
differently for the two data sets
because the data sets had different
characteristics
for the first data set they um there was
geographic metadata that was provided as
part of the data set and so they split
it into metatrading metaval and meta
test sets shown in these different
colors and so they're holding out
different geographic regions in the
meadowvale set in the meta test set
and then they constructed a metal
learning problem by trying to be able to
classify between different kinds of
land such as forest or croplands
given a small number of patches from
that um
from that region of the world
so this is an example of a two-way
two-shot classification task
uh and then for the second data set um
they didn't actually have any geographic
metadata in the data set unfortunately
so they used clustering to try to guess
different regions and then they held out
different clusters for the
metavalidation set and the meta test set
and then they framed a one-shot learning
problem for the segmentation task as the
following where they took a very small
patch of a much larger region they
labeled this as the support set and then
they evaluated the model on the query
set on other patches of the data
and like as an example this kind of
large region is a
image that's like
2400 pixels by 2400 pixels
and the label would look something like
this
uh and what they found in their
evaluation is they compared basically
um
trading on your new data at meta test
time just from scratch
they compared to pre-training on all of
your metadata combined and then
fine-tuning
on this and they also compared to
running mammal on the meta training data
set and adapting to the test data
and what they found is on the first data
set they were able to
first use kind of significantly better
with mammal than with a pre-trained
model and a random model
um in the case where you have between
one and ten shots ten data points
and when you had zero data points the
pre-trained model did the best uh and
this is also what we'd expect because
mammal needs data to fine-tune and of
course the randomly initialized network
also needs data to fine-tune
um also on the deep globe data set they
saw similar results on the clustered
split where they were kind of adapting
to a new region that was held out
whereas when they did a more random
split they found that
the pre-trained network and mammal
performed somewhat similarly when you
have a few shots
okay so this is pretty cool it's kind of
a more
real world application of where metal
learning might be useful when you want
to adapt to different regions of the
world
and then if you're interested there's
kind of more visualizations and more
analysis in the paper and also both of
these data sets are publicly available
if you're interested in studying them
yourself for example for your final
project
okay um so that's it for today we talked
about optimization based metal learning
and uh
the basics of the techniques and how to
trade off
kind of some of the trade-offs between
black box and optimization based
techniques
um
kind of the roadmap for the upcoming
lectures is that next week on monday
we'll have a guest lecture from matt
johnson where he'll talk about automatic
differentiation and how our deep
learning software's actually compute the
derivatives for things that we talked
about today and for just neural networks
in general
and on wednesday we'll start talking
about the last class of metal learners
which is uh non-parametric learners
and we'll also cover kind of a general
comparison of all the three approaches
that we've discussed
and then the following week we'll talk
about more advanced better learning
topics
topics that are also still quite
important though especially if you want
to
use metal learning in your final project
and in week five we'll start
reinforcement learning